not thinking and just kind of going with
the flow trusting his instinct
you can kind of get away with more in
online chess than uh over-the-board
classical chess and wow a bit of a small
surprise here levon opens with a queen
spawn that's not the surprise it's
magnus just pushing the pawn in front of
his king the square he's inviting levon
to occupy the center here with the white
king's pawn we could see a transposition
to the french defence magnus has been
inviting that a few times this
tournament
and uh yeah this one not occupying the
center yet does give levon options
yeah come on i i know what i wanted to
play here obviously oh yeah he's put the
knight in the way of the port no dutch
defense no we get a london system we do
get a london system instead which is
yeah very very very popular opening um
at all levels and something i guess that
magnus plays uh more than
more with the white pieces than we think
aronian plays generally i i guess he's
had some great games in the london
system giving him a taste of his own
medicine maybe levon and this is quite a
clever move order for white it does cut
out some of black's options
and uh okay that just
develops this bishop to a slightly
passive square not the most typical way
of handling the opening
if you did i know there's a popular
thing online called guess the elo
and if if uh black had done that and i
had to guess the eli i'd say like 1200.
[Laughter]
already
maybe i'll go 1500 just because bishop
in front the king there
is a really rare move and you're kind of
committing the bishop to a slightly
passive square it's a peculiar move
there's no doubt about that um you
normally uh try other setups first okay
but now he's following up with um that's
unusual right i was not expecting that
you know normally you pick up that pawn
and move it one square and then you
adopt a completely different formation
this
i've actually never seen before this is
new yeah david have you seen it before
not in this exact position it's quite a
typical idea but here it just feels a
bit loose it feels inconsistent as well
black was just getting ready to castle
the king to safety
okay magnus frowning there he looks a
bit disgusted by his own move but yeah
this black pawn will come under attack
and he'll need to spend a bit more time
defending it yeah okay so i'm just
checking my database uh has been played
once before between gatakamsky who is a
renowned specialist in this particular
opening for white
and i think he's an english grand master
used to be australian but now english
can anyone guess used to be australian i
think yeah or singaporean actually
daniel fernandez daniel fernandez yeah
singaporean i think he's not is he
australian now though
he lives in australia it represents
england yeah yeah he plays it and he's
very famous in the uk circles for just
playing very quirky but i think he got
this idea of another grand master keith
arkham
who daniel fernandez said in an he was
one of his favorite players and uh keith
farquhar used to play this setup with
the white pawns over there i've also
seen peter svidler uh play this in the
the famous bom ratty tournament in in
ireland and uh it's a way to sort my
balance i guess david just to get a bit
of space over there on the queen side
and you know don't don't let white have
all the room on the board so it it it
makes positional sense i i feel to play
this way there's definitely nothing
wrong with what black's doing it's just
maybe a bit provocative because it's not
fighting for the center yet
he's just inviting level one ironian now
that white's pieces are nice and
centralized he's inviting him to push
forward uh in the middle of the board
but okay magnus chipping away at the
center white has erected this really
strong kind of pawn center
typical of the london system
and uh you guys have both played the
london system on occasion right so
what would you be thinking here with
white with uh if you were in lebanon
shoes pretty happy i would be happy i
would simply carry on with the old
formula i would just put my king
i would castle it to the right side and
then i would perhaps connect the two
rooks by stepping the queen up one
square forward to the e2 square and then
i would at the right time destabilize on
the left side of the board with a two a4
yeah
um and yeah i mean this the london
system is is an opening that
um a lot of people have kind of a
love-hate relationship with
especially lower down the low range
because
it is a very good opening to learn and i
don't think there's any doubt about that
whatsoever for lower rated players
because it's what we call a system
you don't really have to memorize
individual moves you have to memorize
ideas it's more important to know the
ideas behind the the moves you're
playing and i think in general that's
really good uh when you're trying to
learn opening know the ideas don't just
make don't memorize things but don't
really know what you're memorizing so
the london system without shadow does
very easy to play you get your pieces in
the game it's a good opening and i know
a lot of players on the black side they
hate playing against the london
assistants that i'm like it's so boring
it's such a boring opening but
my opinion is it's certainly not a
boring opening
it's a very good opening and like most
openings you can play in many different
ways you can actually play incredibly
aggressively and
it's it's been played at top level as
well so i'm a big believer in the london
system actually i think it's a good
opening that you don't have to learn too
much
theory in order to play i think it's a
very practical choice and uh definitely
like you say simon there will be fun and
games you can have lots of adventures
like right now you know white has just
actually occupied the center with a pawn
and this means that trouble and
excitement is brewing and uh just to add
to the fun and games yay well
we are actually gonna have a selfie
competition today and we wanna know how
you're watching the show the tour sorry
and uh who you're watching with and for
a chance to win this magnificent air
things view plus
here it is then tweets ask your selfies
using the hashtag chesschamps
and uh can't wait to see all your
pictures yeah we'll feature them on the
show definitely
you're always so creative all our
viewers it's so much fun to uh to watch
you guys watch us
where you're watching is it inside is it
outside
inception
[Laughter]
yeah tweet your selfies you guys we look
forward to seeing them and we'll show
them on the screen here we do have uh
castling it's a good sign it's a good
sign for both players they have finally
kind of obeyed those opening rules and
that marks the end of the opening both
sides of castled a few things have
happened maybe if we jump in just to
explain what's been going on
we did see white occupy the center this
is maybe not a typical london system
anymore we have seen white occupy the
center which sometimes
white actually doesn't try to do in the
london system normally it's about piece
play just as much as pawn play and uh
here dropping back the bishop uh is not
typical in this uh in this setup i guess
white's idea is he just wants to keep
these pawns intact as long as possible
and as long as he keeps these pawns here
it's gonna be very difficult for black
to challenge
and uh fight for space it's gonna be
difficult for black to maybe find nice
squares for his pieces i'm expecting
maybe at some point the white queen to
just sit um just kind of to
connect the white rooks just move out
the way at some point where i can move
his rook across the other rook can come
across and it's just a bit of a waiting
game will black ever be able to fight uh
for those central squares for example if
we just see a pawn capture um then it's
always a challenge for black which pawn
do you push in the middle of the board
you can't just sit there and wait
forever eventually you need to break out
the problem is if you push this pawn
white will gain space and block things
up opening up a nice diagonal towards
the black king and if you push the other
pawn then again same problem black's
knight will have to retreat uh white has
gained space in the process and often
black is left with a bit of a dead piece
just staring against a stronghold in the
center for white so um i'm very
interested to see firstly how levon
aronia just goes about improving the
white pieces
and whether he moves the queen
one of the rooks maybe those would be
what i would be looking at at least but
um second question yeah sorry david i
just wonder if you're worried about
knight b4 in any of these positions or
is something you think uh just just
personally intrigued there because i'd
be quite worried about that night coming
here but maybe maybe i don't need to be
yeah maybe in this position uh hitting
the bishop if there is an exchange and
if the bishop drops back maybe the black
knight can jump in
so
uh a case very surprising for me levon
aronian he has exchanged first maybe
just afraid of your idea simon that and
now he's moved the queen so he's lost uh
some influence in the center but at
least the black knight can never jump
forward
gives up his center i don't like that
decision at all i have to say you know
because my understand i'm such a space
monster i love the center pawns i mean i
would have perhaps prevented that might
move in a different way not like this
this feels like
black is doing well now all of a sudden
you know his pieces have got great
squares great diagonals the queen you
know she can easily vacate the bottom
line and can there she goes the rooks
are connected and it's only white who's
going to be challenging for that sorry
it's only black who's going to be
primed to challenge the the open line
yeah black is ready to put his rook on
this nice open line uh also
it feels like levon's playing on the
wrong side of the board he's trying to
undermine pawns here but now after this
pawn push black has the advantage on
this left flank uh black has the more
advanced pawn therefore black has more
space and here i wouldn't be surprised
if magnus starts maneuvering his knight
around
this is quite a common idea maybe you
can maneuver it into the center as well
but uh for example if white just waits
then jumping in with this knight you
have all sorts of ideas uh white doesn't
really want to give up the bishop paying
capture this night but later on you're
attacking this square you've got
outposts you've got squares to jump into
and what's white doing in the meantime
it seems far-fetched to imagine any
attack brewing against the black king
black's king
doesn't have too many pieces around it
but white will need
kind of miracles just to
push some pieces towards it i've got no
idea what leb's doing yeah i gotta be
totally honest
um
that pawn capture giving up his really
big pawn in the centre of boarding is so
surprising because
you give black to monstrous squares
david you just pointed out one with the
knight and you give up these two dark
squares because you've lost your central
pawn well you've exchanged it black has
a space advantage
you you've given up space and i i i
normally when you see someone so strong
playing an idea that's like you haven't
seen before there's a definite
idea behind it there's a definite
positive plan but i i don't know what
what lev's plan is in this position i
can't i can't really see it so he's lost
the flexibility of that pawn center and
i agree with you simon and david i just
don't like it yeah i mean not that's not
saying that he's kind of massively worse
as white it's just no transfer of
advantage he's definitely the one
playing for
uh survival here levon ironing for
equality i guess levon's idea is maybe
at some point if black kind of does
nothing to drop his knight back and just
initiate a whole bunch of exchanges in
the center but
again that's not playing for the
advantage that's just plain to draw with
white yeah very surprising stuff i do
feel that magnus at the most ambitious
okay wow kind of guessed his move by
accident he does actually push this pawn
forward just creating some squares for
his king later on just in case
but at some point magnus will drop the
knight back and start swinging it
towards the side of the board and
don't really see what white's doing in
the meantime very difficult white can
never really arrange pushing this pawn
forward in any favorable way and if he
can't push this pawn forward he will
never get an attack i see
someone mentioning my courses on the on
the london system i certainly wouldn't
put this game in as a recommended way to
play uh for white and there was many
more options i i yeah it's just very
peculiar isn't it i i the way that um
maybe he's throwing a bit of uh
nervousness or fear because he's playing
magnus which is very peculiar for lev as
well but i can't really explain this way
playing in some ways it's a little bit
negative i feel um to play this way
because
you're giving up you're giving up your
chances for an advantage and you're just
trying to i think go for equality now
with the white pieces so it's a peculiar
peculiar start to the game here well
what's funny is that you when you look
at the play you're like i agree with
everything you say simon but when you
when the camera was on live on
it like
happy days
look like he was in a good mood and that
uh he got his normal good mood though
isn't he he's normally smiling probably
if he's getting checkmated in three
moves he'd be doing a little jig as well
but um
i mean
i don't know i mean
is the idea to bring the knight into the
center or saying no okay still playing
on the queen side this looks like a
decent idea just swapping off pieces
white does uh kind of suffer from a
space disadvantage so it makes sense to
kind of trade off pieces but uh no he
does play on the queen side he's just
trying to undermine
uh the foremost pawn for black the
furthest advanced of the pawn chain and
this makes sense i guess if there's a
pawn trade here then i'm not sure which
way white captures but either way at
least you have pressure on this pawn if
these guys disappear it's just all pawns
on one side of the board likely to be
level likely to be a draw later on so if
all pawns disappear i think levon is
safe it's just magnus pausing right now
and uh can he keep
kind of keep the integrity of his pawn
chain can he keep these guys intact
no not an easy job maybe we'll see
lebron just kind of hoover off all the
pieces
yeah you sometimes wonder about b4 don't
you know in these positions but i i
don't think it's working here i mean
it's just a typical way to try to you
know unbalance stuff but you mentioned
it before me simon before
very nice you are the king of the
panzers
this makes some sense it's a bit of a
face-off between these pawns uh these
four pawns here uh but either way it
looks like all of them eventually will
just get traded off yeah yeah they are
facing off live on our onion and magnus
carlson sitting inside the esports arena
in miami and right outside the arena we
have a reporter
out in the nice miami weather what's the
weather report today sweater
these are the kind of days i think the
weather report is
absolutely wonderful
chess weather pretty much this is
actually in my opinion the best weather
for being a chess reporter i think
that's where we're going to settle it so
outside here of the eden rock hotel i
have a wonderful guest with me as well i
have tour director arna
and
anna one of the talking points going
into today was a tweet coming from hans
neiman he's saying i'm going to let the
chess speak for myself for itself i'm
not going to do any interviews
as a tour director what do you think
about that
well i think that is first and foremost
uh cool tweet from hans nema that he is
kind of bantering with us
and let him have fun with that and i do
think that he's gonna
stop by you at some point today anyhow
so that's that's just cool no neiman
bantry you really think so i think that
might happen from time to time yes
well i mean we are currently at this
wonderful eden rock hotel i mean if
we're looking at the background of you
right now we're seeing blue waters we're
seeing an amazing beach how did you even
come about this as a chess venue
well when you looking to new things you
really have to take it
to the next level
coming here to miami it's uh what is in
the dialogue with the fdx we decided
that uh miami should be the venue for
uh for this cup and then to find the
right location we actually went here a
couple of months ago and did veneer
scouting and then found the indirect
hotel and just decided this is the place
to be amazing to be here as organizers
and i do believe also the players really
enjoy being here because the field is
amazing i mean we've gotten so many top
players it it must have been an easy yes
from a lot of the players that
especially those who weren't necessarily
qualified
indeed both with the prize fund and the
extra bitcoin price from here and the
surroundings and the tempo we have here
everything they can do on the side as
well they're really enjoying it it's
called the ftx crypto cup and ftx is not
only a sponsor for this event they're
really a partner they're playing an
active part in this whole tournament as
well indeed we in in partnership with
the fdx we have also done this so that
we
set the strike price of one hundred
thousand dollars in bitcoin and
following that throughout the tournament
and that is really cool to be involved
with uh with a partner in that way as
well
so as you can tell kaya we're we're
really suffering here in the miami sun
you know it's it's a tough job but
someone's got to do it
oh i feel so sorry for you and i have to
say arnold looking very cool with his
sunglasses there i was wondering how
about you guys join our selfie
competition today can we see a selfie
from you guys posted on twitter on the
hashtag chesschamps
can we do a selfie arnold kaya is asking
us for that
i mean i mean he this is a proactive man
he's a tour director he's already up
with his phone and
i'm
saying we're ready to go we're
definitely doing the selfie competition
i hope everyone else joins as well
because someone has got to look prettier
than this guy at least and maybe even
you i think maybe maybe
you didn't you didn't remember to do
landscape mode you've got
do a landscape mode as well and post it
on hashtag chess champs for a chance to
win uh the very cool air things the
viewplus
thank you arna and zbada in miami
i'm looking forward to seeing that
selfie on twitter and we heard a lot of
moves coming out in the game magnus
thinking for three minutes before he
made some moves yeah a lot of moves and
uh magnus's time
it's a bit worrying for him down to
seven minutes levon up at 12 and the
whole queen side all of the pawns have
disappeared they've all been traded off
as we kind of predicted and uh this last
move
is lev on aronian maybe threatening a
sacrifice here does he have some nasty
uh plans up his sleeve let's jump in to
see what happened
and uh here we left the position just
after levon aronian had pushed his pawn
forward we did see this pawn captured
and magnus thought okay these pawns are
equally weak let's just trade those uh
trade those off as well and now jumping
into the center with the white knight
and at first i thought oh this hangs
upon black is attacking this pawn once
twice with his pieces but if black takes
this pawn i guess level neronian's idea
is to maybe sacrifice on this square and
it's just chaos i'm really struggling to
calculate this to be honest but at the
very least white will give a check maybe
take off the black rook and black's
pieces do look very loose they are all
pretty much undefended and it just feels
like something might drop long term this
one is very complicated this is the type
of thing magnus has to calculate and
evaluate
this type of sacrifice this check and if
you want to stop the sacrifice knight
takes pawn
what do you do as magnus and okay he
brings his queen into the center it does
cover this square it also potentially
threatens rook takes knight winning two
pieces for a rook
but it does feel a bit loose again this
queen now on a square can be attacked at
the very least levon aronian can drop
his knight back to where it came from
and attack the queen and maybe ask
magnus are you ready to repeat the
position are you ready to put your queen
on a different
square what do you guys think it feels
it feels as if something's about to
happen there's no despite the fact that
all the queen side pawns have been
traded there's still all the heavy
pieces on the board all the minor pieces
as well
i mean it looks like he's he's walking
into a pawn attack there yeah with the
queen i mean um that'd be the first move
that i consider just just to attack the
queen with a pawn i kind of want to go
aggressive here use those pawns
uh aronian's light square bishop as you
pointed out is a fantastic piece
and the knight combined with that is
very good and this kind of a formation
of using two pawns to
improve the range of the light square
bishop in some cases can was it was an
idea bobby fischer used very often
in uh the sicilian opening um and it
might be something that at least scares
me a bit here with the black pieces i'm
finding magnus's queen e5
a bit peculiar to be honest and and we
have had this on the board and i don't
know if you push that pawn again uh or
you could even consider pushing the
other pawn it just uh it's like magnus
is saying to aronian play this move and
it's like i'd be so scared to allow that
pawn to come forwards with tempo i mean
that would terrify me i never allow that
move to occur so i'm
you know i'm just a bit surprised by by
that move that magnus played yeah it's
very surprising especially because the
queen has now just dashed back to
the b8 square as well
and uh i mean the sacrifices that david
mentioned as well the knight takes born
still in the air
um
i also really terrified of your move
lengthening the bishop simon and
yeah i just don't get it
yeah it's just provocation that's been
magnus's kind of calling card this
tournament so far it feels like every
day every game he's in the mood to
provoke his opponent and i think long
term despite the fact he's lost a move
with the black queen he's hoping that
this move actually weakens white's king
white's king will have less protection i
guess long term as well this bishop has
some ideas uh along this diagonal white
central pawns are quite weak but it's
just about whether he can survive the
next few moves and um the sacrifice is
the key uh the key question right now
can white get away with taking uh this
pawn i guess we would see an exchange
here and black's king run away to safety
and uh white can take this rook might as
well the question is here white has rook
and two pawns for two minor pieces black
in return has a bishop and a knight
which
is better what's the better assortment i
have no idea to be honest it's so hard
to judge
on one hand you could make an argument
for white's pawns being strong on the
other hand you could make an argument
for black's bishops being very
kind of having a lot of potential here
and especially if you push the pawns
forward you just give away squares to
black's minor pieces they start jumping
in they start threatening stuff
so yeah really hard to evaluate magnus
provoking levon ford and levon has to
decide does he go all in and just
capture this pawn now and take a big
risk in a position that's so irrational
and hard to judge or does he maybe play
a quieter move i mean i like your one
simon to be honest the question i guess
is where to go if black just blocks it
you have one great piece but maybe
that's uh
that's it for now
yeah if there's not a follow-up there
then maybe it's some mood to avoid but i
mean even here
you know obviously
i'm looking at sacrificing the bishop
and throwing the knight in but if i'm
gonna do it or throw in the knight in
but if i'm gonna do that i should
probably just take that pawn in the
first place why am i doing it this way
around maybe even the other pawn as well
is you can think about moving that first
and then in some cases i'd love to move
the f pawn now but it might not work
because the queen takes pawn
but this is the kind of thing that lev
will certainly be calculating because
those pawns you know they they're very
dangerous if they can get motoring but i
don't think it works here
but he's certainly going to be looking
at all these possibilities there's a lot
there's a lot to consider in the
position i mean the position is also so
open that maybe white can even think
about bringing extra pieces to the
attack so also i was kind of inspired by
magnus and thinking you know maybe i can
put the rook uh line it up against the
queen and i'm banking on
the activity
just to kind of offset this uh plane
that's up for grabs on e5 before one
thing i'm amazed at is just the
provocation dave david and ivanka that
this queen e5 move from magnus you
mentioned it david i would never think
of provoking a move like that it just
shows a different level of understanding
how many players will play queen e5
there
i don't know anyone who played that move
to willingly go into this dangerous
looking position yeah
yeah he's literally lost a move as you
mentioned simon here i mean he could
have he could have just retreated his
queen immediately but he has the same
position now with white's pawn on the
square he has gone for it we did see
stockfish uh the computer moves there on
our screens for a moment and um the
computer after this queen jumping
forward and retreating it did say the
white's best move was to indeed capture
this pawn and he's gone for it love on
ironian and uh after capture here this
is a check a double attack and at the
very end we saw white's bishop capture
so it is that scenario of rook and two
pawns
sorry
my arrow is getting confused again there
but it is rook and two pawns for two
black pieces
and uh
i will take the pieces i think yeah i
mean there's a famous book chess icicles
the only book actually written in the
north pole um when exploring north pole
yeah the explorer was up there and he
got stuck out
okay i'm just making up yeah yeah
oh
you got it first
okay i i nearly see you i'm sure i could
have had someone there
no but it's a very it didn't work it's
very interesting
i don't think i'm going to pass that one
anymore am i
chess icicles where did that come from i
i completely believed you i could have
tried a bit more there couldn't i nearly
you had me you just need to team up with
these
just look at me like you idiot simon you
idiots and i was like okay
[Music]
yeah yeah i didn't think what was the
name
chess icicles by an explorer on the
north pole there we have it it was a
little bit too extreme really wasn't it
yeah
um but yeah it's very interesting in
balance isn't it i mean normally the
two-minute piece is a bit easier to play
would you say david in the position or
especially with
less time on your clock especially in
rapid chess blitz chess the conventional
wisdom says you'd rather take minor
pieces just because there are two of
them white pawns
they have a role to play but white's
rooks it's not clear where they go
whereas okay magnus there singing along
to some song clearly uh but wow okay
white's diving in i was going to say
it's not clear where the brooks go uh
but this looks like a very odd choice of
square it just looks so loose somehow
it's defended by white's bishop white
star square bishop but
it can get kicked away yeah and uh it
does get kicked away
yeah trade of dark squared bishops and
suddenly white has a real dilemma
the white rook is loose and also there
is a pawn
after okay i was going to say after the
white rook retreats black's queen could
have come out and captured white's f
pawn but no that's no longer possible
black's queen is tied down to her bishop
in one way that's a good exchange for
white i quite like what's just happened
the transition because black no longer
has a bishop pair
previously black had two bishops white
only had one now one bishop alone might
not do the job but at the same time
white's rooks do make an odd impression
they're either very strong or they're
very kind of poorly placed
how do you guys think of this very very
unusual position i have to say i haven't
seen it actually two rooks lined up on
that but uh they don't have nowhere to
go to
and uh i mean maybe the big issue is
like whether white's uh e porn is
actually gonna get motoring and whether
it will actually do some damage in terms
of just distracting the black forces
yeah it's black smooth so he needs to
come up with something quick he needs to
somehow attack those white rooks kick
them away or kind of destabilize them
i'm not sure you want to
touch the black queen right now i don't
think the black rook
maybe you could make an argument from it
bring the black rook down to the second
rank uh where it has some targets but
um yeah you definitely need to create
some threats as magnus before as you
mentioned the white pawns start pushing
forward in the center it's one of those
positions where you know either side
plays one bad move it can collapse
because it's very very tactical and
i i think one of the things that people
forget to consider in positions middle
game positions like this is just uh how
much time you have and the urgency in
the position and when you've got a
position that's so open open lines
pieces everywhere um you have to play
with more urgency and and there's
there's more to worry about and you have
to every move counts that much more
rather than a safe position that's
closed up here i mean for example if the
rook comes down maybe maybe the white
queen can jump in it's like you know i
don't there's so much stuff to to
consider here
um one bad move and it could it could
you know go wrong so it's
i i mean i like messy positions
generally but this would be a headache
to play for both sides really really
complex stuff yeah
you mentioned this rook coming in and
white could jump forward and suddenly
everything's under fire right this
bishop this knight white knight is under
fire i mean there's all these captures
that you just i mean it's so easy to get
confused as a human here maybe the black
queen could jump in and capture a pawn
it's just chaos there's captures all
over the place
and uh it's not clear whose king is
safer to be honest
but yeah i mean i'd be fascinated to see
the top computer choice because for me i
wouldn't even know where to start i
would look at the threats maybe such as
bringing the rook down to the second
rank maybe such as bringing the knight
to the square hitting the rook in the
corner
maybe if you want to play it safe
retreat the knight hit this rook
but it's not clear where to start and
which one to kind of
normally there are two clear variations
and you compare them you decide okay at
the end of this one i have an easy
position to play at the end of the other
one maybe i have a slight disadvantage
here who knows
it's just that kind of position and
that's why i think levon is looking so
confident and relaxed because he's
saying okay magnus he's thinking he's
lower on the clock right now i'll just
react to whatever black does
and sometimes that's the best strategy
in such wild positions okay the knight
does indeed go back and kick away this
rook
and it's kind of like there's there's
pieces and pawns all over the board it's
like you have to keep your eye on
everything and
all squares on this board is that
difficult yeah extremely difficult
sometimes it's nice having lots of pawns
because then at least it's one half of
the board is blocked you can focus on
one
kind of one corner but here you need to
focus on for example this side of the
board later on you need to be careful
the black king doesn't get checked uh i
was about to say if the rook retreats
suddenly you have to worry about the
black queen jumping from one side to the
other capturing a pawn suddenly black
would be winning so you can't retreat
the rook you have to counter-attack
and uh counter-attacking against this
rook now means that
uh yeah big question again for magnus i
don't think you want to exchange because
suddenly black has lost his rook black
has lost control over the lines the
files
and white really is ready to start
pumping these pawns forward
i suppose the danger for magnus i mean
i'm thinking maybe magnus is in more
danger here because generally if the
queens come off then white is doing very
well that's when the rook can be more
powerful than the two minor pieces i
would have thought um so magnus kind of
has to
i i would imagine just avoid exchanging
queens at least yeah so it's like a
little bit more danger for black here
you know being careful what pieces are
exchanged where white doesn't have to
worry about that you can offer exchange
of queens and you have to keep
counter-attacking as he does here i mean
he's keeping the frets going uh
attacking that knight in the middle of
the board uh and it's just it's just a
mess i mean this position really hard to
play um really really hard it's like
someone's just throwing the pieces on
the board yeah i mean i was gonna say
you know it seems to me that every
single move just needs to be assessed on
a move by move basis
uh safety first both sides are just
looking to kind of anchor their pieces
and also at the same time give them good
purpose i like magnus's last move you
know putting his mind on the same square
safe square and uh releasing the light
squared bishop but doesn't have a threat
though
like yeah i mean this is this is a
position we talked about the london
system is a system where you you can
talk about the ideas behind the moves
this is more a calculating position so
you have positions where you can
generalize more but this position does
you can't really generalize that much
right it is as you said it is a move by
move like one move will change will
change the whole position it's very
tactical
and
you know it's not easy to just find you
know generalize what both side sides
should be doing here yeah
for me i mean i would the only thing i
would say is both sides must activate
their pieces the end
and protect the king both sides again
have to always look after their king
because it could be getting checkmated
one wrong move a piece is going to fall
off
and uh
oh
okay double attack from levon iranian
hitting black's rook and black's bishop
with the white queen and magnus reacts
by defending everything
the black queen oh okay levon herroni is
shaking his head there i don't like the
fact that white kind of decentralized
his queen uh white's queen it was just
kind of a one move threat that's the
type of thing that maybe when we're
starting chess we are very attracted to
just kind of double attack and sometimes
they work but if they don't then you
might have worsened your pieces in the
process and suddenly
white pawns in the center both of them
are under fire yeah i mean the queen was
doing such a good defensive and
aggressive job there on the e3 square
now the black the white king sorry is
vulnerable it can be exposed
and open to a check on the diagonal and
uh black's pieces are now suddenly very
well poised to start attacking the e4
pawn um
i think black is actually much better
now
yeah seems like the first mistake right
maybe yeah it's been a very high quality
game actually despite the fact it's been
so complicated usually we would see
mistakes or at least
some mistakes here and there in such a
wild position but
um yeah i'm not sure about much better i
would still i would take black but
uh i would still think that with best
play white should be okay somehow
somehow here
um maybe the best move is bringing the
white queen back where she came from
um
yeah what else the white rooks they're
just struggling to kind of break into
the position
the
squares the white rooks want to use like
going to the top of the board those
squares are all covered
by black's bishop i just checked the
computer evaluations and suggestions and
i have to say it is dangling on knife
edge for white the best move is as you
suggest
put the queen back to its original
square the e3 square second move is
actually just the counter attack and
attack the rook
if you don't do those two moves
that's it
you're going to lose
it's very hard though isn't it admitting
you just played a bad move
and moving your queen back you know
that's one of the hardest things in
chess to do to like basically okay that
move was rubbish i'm gonna have to put
the queen back there i've lost like two
tempo i mean uh no one likes doing that
uh and you know just
admitting the mistakes that they've done
so yeah i mean do you think he'll play
that david put the queen back or do you
think he'll go for something else here i
think the only way irony will ever play
that move is just by process of
elimination he can't find anything else
and then he'll admit that okay he's lost
two moves he'll bring the uh bring the
white queen back to the middle but
it's incredibly hard use uh like you say
psychologically i don't think that's the
first move he's looking at he's going to
be looking at all sorts of threats maybe
hitting the black rook hitting the black
bishop
but
so you sort of keep trying to find
something else because you don't want to
play it exactly and he has played
something else he's played this other
move you mentioned juventus um which is
is a counter attack because he didn't
want to admit that his queen move was a
mistake really but and now now it's
getting even more complicated it's so
hard to work out first game of the day
give us some nice london system grind
please no pieces everywhere no we want
chess like this because it is it's great
to watch and these two players always
provide entertainment don't they they're
like like
uh magnus said before the game lev comes
at everyone yeah including magnus he has
no fear
and he has he's done that approach in
this game yeah and that's the thing i
mean these two players they've played
each other hundreds of times in their
life but no two games are ever the same
there's always some kind of uh they just
make it unique somehow they make it
chaotic like this and
um yeah right now black's rook is under
fire what would you i was about to say
do you give a check well this is i mean
is he picking up a pawn here with czech
he is really isn't that just massive
yeah i think white's saving grace is to
try and swap off the queens and right if
white can get the queens off like you
said uh earlier at least some of the
danger is gone whiten has lost a pawn in
the process so it's not great if there's
a queen trade black would win another
pawn but magnus wow
getting greedy grabbing everything i
mean hasn't this just completely
collapsed i mean you've lost two of your
you've lost two of your main assets
there i mean you might better have some
drawing chances you said because all the
pawns are on one side of the board the
queen's come off
yeah if the queen's come off but it's a
long way for getting the queens off here
as well and uh i mean this has obviously
taken a really bad uh nose dive for
aronian this position so far yeah he's
essentially just lost two pawns so now
black has the advantage of bishop and
knight worth six points against the rook
worth five points
so upper material and yeah those black
pieces once they combine
they will do some damage white's king is
probably the weak of the two black's
king has a nice safe square to hide on
and uh white's king will come under fire
from both black knights at some point
okay a retreat is mysterious yeah
another another strange move i thought
there because i i guess white should be
trying to exchange pieces right
and you could have exchanged a pair of
knights there um
with a night jump attacking the queen
because i think when you got this
position where you got the rook against
your opponent's two pieces
as we said we want to get the queen off
the board you want to get down to as an
ending really you just want to make
exchanges get rid of your opponent's
dangerous pieces so a little bit
surprised by that um
question is though can magnus now uh
take advantage of what should be a good
position for black or
can white just hold everything because
pawns are not going to really play a
part now are they it's just pieces
definitely you know there's one night
that's not really working and that's the
night on e7 so it might be a good idea
to mobilize that also the white rook is
on is on the same line as the black
queen
is this maybe something to think about
and uh take some pre-emptive
moves against that yeah so it's not
clear who feels more uncomfortable the
white rook or the black queen in the
middle they're just kind of staring off
at each other yeah i wouldn't be
surprised if magnus moves the queen that
would be a safe option
um this this position reminds me of a
phrase that levon aronian used a couple
of days ago in his interview there we go
ivanka improving one of the black
knights
but levon he said katanachio like this
kind of all
backs to the wall defensive
job just
all hands on deck just hold the fort and
i think that's what he'll try to do
he'll just try and curl up into a ball
and
maybe start by moving the white rook
retreating the white knight just kind of
putting all the pieces around the white
king and saying okay i don't think you
can break through
is category the same as park the bus
similar similar okay i had never heard
of this expression it's an italian
phrase uh
yeah
it's
from some football matches do you use
the term park the bus in chess or is
that only football
yeah i think you can do it in chess i've
parked the bus anytime
can you imagine you're a park the bus
player
[Laughter]
when everything's gone wrong there's
nothing else to do why not park the bus
yeah
i've never really heard that before part
of the bus i mean
no no i haven't so
thank god i feel i don't know he's
probably saying i'm just not aware of so
much
yeah i mean while just the pieces are
dancing around just finding safer
squares
i quite like what levon's done the last
couple of moves but of course he's still
trying to park that bus
white knight oh it's on a bit of a loose
square actually you've got to be careful
where you put it
do you really have to retreat to the
bottom of the board it's a big threat
right now black wants to capture the
white knight and
there might be some nasty checks the
black queen jumping into the center with
a check looks horrendous says i mean if
you compare the safety of the two kings
white's king is now getting attacked you
can't offer the exchange of queens
because your rook will
fold
and uh black's knights are ready to jump
in black's king completely safe
um you know it can just move one square
forwards at any position and here they
come
here come the knights and uh there's a
major tactical threat here as well right
i mean just uh to win the game
medially and i'm not even sure what what
white can do to stop that yeah if white
were to for example push a pawn or do
something uh non-committal maybe this
move uh moving into the center of the
queen simon the forced win actually
there's two forced twins here they work
in both orders uh one you can jump in
with a knight with a check this is a
fork deflecting away the white queen and
now the white rook would drop you win a
piece in the process uh or you can flip
the order of this exact same tactic and
you can first take the rook and then
after sacrificing your queen jump in
with a check and uh here's it's even
better you win two pieces you're two
pieces up so white's rook was under fire
uh as simon mentions there and it had to
run away this night check was too
scary and now it's just a matter of how
do you combine these four pieces
against the white king
you've got the knight stabled
as well
even in this position the bishop is
controlling the knight a little bit here
at least great piece there in the middle
of the board kept in its box
i mean black's pieces are all very
nicely centralized here um maybe you
bring another knight in i was going to
say centralized the other night this is
this is a david move
yeah this is imaginatively that magnus
has been spending too much time with
david clear with that move you know so
you love those moves don't you exactly
just look at the black king now there's
never going to be a check against it and
you can kind of refocus your efforts on
the white king
at least if the king was kind of here
white would always be able to kind of
gain a bit of time uh hitting the king
but not anymore and now level iranian
reacts to that kind of nice kind of
hiding the king move to he reacts to it
by retreating maybe he wants to use his
rook just as a shield on this square or
potentially this square but i agree with
you guys it's time to get this knight
into the game the other three pieces
look great
so maybe centralize it this way
not sure where you're going next at some
point later you'll try and start
attacking the king from one angle or or
the other it's very close to having
bishop takes porn uh here as well
um i you know
nearly working is is why is it working
is the
idea after
yeah yeah but
magnus just improves his night and uh
lavon you know he's just really
struggling here he's not going to do it
and the black queen can attack from this
angle
she can later attack from this this type
of angle as well
white's king is just going to
really suffer the next few moves and
look at the black pieces i mean these
two are just fantastic
just pointing down the weakness actually
in white's camp you mentioned it simon
there's always going to be tactics
against this pawn
it's on a light square after all it's
going to be targeted kind of x-ray with
the bishop but also with the knight if
you could get the other black knight to
kind of combine somehow and hit this
pawn it would just be game over
but uh magnus still needs the
breakthrough
he still wants to break through this
kind of uh park the bus formation
navon is trying to set up channeling his
inner mourinho level neronian
and so far doing a good job i guess yeah
but uh it has worked for him in the past
as well uh in his previous two matches
he's managed to park the bus and defend
some horrific positions it's gonna be
said but uh against the world champion
it's another mata okay white's king is
safe now for the moment but i'm
wondering whether the other black knight
can start jumping in i love this move
because the knight is now threatening a
big check i think david right with some
beautiful
um
mating formations starting to appear
around white's king there yeah and
saying what can white do i mean this
pawn is about to drop we could see a
result any moment maybe levon will give
up because
how do you save this pawn okay he tries
to save it by swapping queens
may be a good idea but it feels like
there should be a breakthrough somehow
yeah i mean the pieces are so close
there is a night check this is the first
move that sort of grabs my attention um
when the king has to go to back one
square because otherwise it's a big
night for can
um
is there a killer blow here i mean at
the very minimum you just trade off the
queens and then you win this pawn and
then you probably win another pawn and
he should uh be able to grind that out
but magnus will want more yeah in the
current position he'll be looking for a
way okay he does go for your check simon
he'll be looking for a way to uh go for
this white king he's gone for that he's
gone for the clinical finish i think um
which is a simple approach yeah check
winning a pawn the white king only has
one square and he takes this guy too
and uh yeah these two pawns eventually
will win the game for example white can
even win two pieces for his rook now he
can capture the bishop and uh kind of
win two pieces back but the problem is
black emerges with two extra pawns and
slowly eventually this is winning i was
gonna ask you though i mean because i
have seen people draw this particular
end game because they've been a little
bit careless i mean
is this uh
super easy to win or you
yes i think
i've had it a couple of times myself uh
throughout my career and those two pawns
as long as you don't kind of push them
too hastily as long as you use your king
i think it's pretty straightforward
it should be if you can get your knight
out of there if you can get your minor
pieces maybe a bit closer to your king i
guess and just push
probably probably pretty easy we could
get down to knight and bishop versus
king do do we think magnus knows that
one or
kim can we demonstrate it to the world
it's more of a question of how much time
does he need on the clock to checkmate
with the bushman knight should i reckon
he could do it with
well with increment you could do it any
time whatsoever so
without increment how much 10 seconds
maybe 15 seconds 20 seconds that'd be a
good challenge
what do you reckon how much time you
think you'd need david i i remember back
in 2015 and
i was doing some work with fabiano
caruana and then we were kind of testing
each other i think he managed to do it
in about 15 seconds took me about 20 25
seconds maybe wow yeah but that was from
the white king starting in the middle of
the board where it's harder to check
mate it's very hard nice and bishop yeah
yeah but these top players they know all
the checkmating patterns if it's
theoretically winning they will win it
yeah and uh it certainly looks like a
winning position for magnus so i'm going
to quickly sneak in
on a hallway selfie yeah
who sansa's greeting from miami beach oh
there they are
they didn't take the photo in landscape
i forgot to announce that it has been
landscaping
and uh whilst
magnus is contemplating a second move i
can also quickly show abhishek's uh
selfie
and
he says ink ideas for david howell in
case he's interested in astronomy
are you interested in astronomy david um
not yet but
i'm interested in tattoos in general i'm
not open to ideas yeah but ink ideas is
in that oh it's a tattoo right yes what
is it it's a planet i'm actually really
into astronomy what planet is that then
is that saturn
it was saturn saturn yeah with the rings
and saturn well that's a good idea then
for people to send in selfies with their
tattoos for some ideas for david
if he's gonna get us at you at some
point yeah i'm i've been looking for the
right design i've had suggestions of a
bishop on the inner arm or
something chest related but i'm still
still looking for the perfect if it was
a chess piece that you would get which
chest would it be the bishop it would be
maybe the bishop pear
okay meanwhile black's king is on the
edge of the board but it's pretty safe
why don't you get them like here like
horns
two bishops there yeah yeah
the opponents
body modifications you know so they
thought
i couldn't hold this or maybe just glue
them to your head
actually uh
during the olympiad recently um
someone i know very well they mentioned
that i seem to like my bishops that i
won my games mostly because i got the
bishop and for some reason my opponents
were just giving them to me every game
and uh it's funny that sometimes
non-chess players spot these little
patterns that uh even experienced
grandmasters didn't realize oh so yeah
it would definitely be bishops uh if
it's bishop if anything just related
okay david's very good at bashing the
bishops bashing the bishops
and the magnus's bishop looks really
strong here as well
magnus's bishop holding all the light
squares soon the pawns will start
rolling on the dark squares
and it's uh yeah the bar definitely all
the way over to minus crossing
in this first game in their rapid match
remember it's uh four rapid games to
decide the match and magnus may be going
up in the lead in the match and also
hans niemann look at that game one
against pragnanda is hans nimon again
winning the first game of today against
pragnanda who is in the lead in the
tournament together with magnus after
two matches the bar all the way over
johannes side oh that's super exciting
yeah
also in part because of whether he will
give the interview yeah will he kind of
refuse or will he kind of just say yeah
we need banter yeah
is chess is doing the talking for him at
the moment yeah he did in the first
round yesterday didn't as well so yeah
he's very sharp in the start of the day
hans nimon yeah he couldn't keep it up
yesterday and that's going to be so cool
to see if he can do today against a very
strong pragnanda the moves are coming
out this magnus
getting closer to that win he's i think
so or further away i think so but uh
he's done it in a bit of a weird way
right
so he's left his bishop attacked but he
is counter-attacking against the white
knight in the center of the board he's
just trying to trade off white's knight
in order to remove any remaining risk
i think there were maybe smoother ways
he's doing it kind of by tactics in
order to win it's probably good enough
for white but
for black here sorry but uh yeah just
feel like he's giving iranians some
chances there has been a result however
there has been a result hans niemann
a win against pragnanda wow the start to
the day for hans nimon he lost his match
against magnus carlsen yesterday and we
have been curious to see if he will tilt
but this is just
a super strong mentality by the young
american
on his home soil one point taking the
lead in the match he's like the hulk
just anger makes him stronger yeah uh
neiman yeah he's a quick starter in the
match did we get an interview
i hope so yeah but you know he said he
wouldn't give interviews so let's uh
let's see if your fingers crossed
well i hope he does a one-liner but
obviously with a different catchphrase
there's a concern that would be awesome
okay and
magnus is simply just rearranging the
knights so he's getting ready to escort
that g pawn to the first row so it can
become a queen and aronian only has 10
seconds it's ticking down
it's now gone to six seconds
a massive threat on the board as well
the black knight wants to come and check
that white king how do you stop it this
is just a kind of spike check now for
aronian he's trying to hope the black
king doesn't have a safe square to hide
on but
i can see at least one safe square and
uh there we go no more checks black's
knight is pinned but uh black's king
will do a little bit of a dance and
evade all of the potential attacks and
it's coming closer all of the black
pieces know how they're coordinated
combined defending each other
it's just great harmony between them and
barring any miraculous stale matrix
i think this one is uh over now
the black king can continue marching
into the position
yeah but uh can't the uh
second knight now join in the operation
looks pretty deadly
here it comes checkmate is actually
coming white's king is in a mating net
they can't escape he's
inevitable now checkmate in a few moves
black's knight coming to give a check
then the pawn will deliver checkmate
pawn check makes it quite rare there you
go
he's thrown in the towel it's a win four
magnus carlsen after 69 moves in game
one against lavon aronian black pieces
for magnus and a fantastic